the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
contents unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival remember
the ship this here is huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
use clear
to me is a fine belt No Doubt
[Applause]
something right to party animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship
everywhere
evil isn't bored
powerful evil
guys
in night it rings our blood he's just
like
we call him Dracula
he's coming
did you see the size of that bloody
thing
[Music]
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all